bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans saour
garde au sommaire ce soir la voiture
électrique à 100 € par mois s'agit-il
d'une opération marketing d'Emmanuel
Macron ou faut-il y voir une vraie
révolution qui va démocratiser les
voitures électriques on en débat dans
quelques instants avec nos invités nos
affranchis ce soir nous serons avec
Mariette darigrand qui nous parlera
politique aïie c'est le mot de la
semaine
et puis notre avocat préféré Bertrand
Perrier évoquera la façon dont les
écoles accueillent les élèves en
transition de genre la chronique Bourbon
Express elsamond d'ingava nous livrera
le dernier les derniers éléments du
feuilleton lié à la loi immigration
cette loi et la recherche d'un accord
avec les républicains on en parlera
justement avec notre grand invité
Benjamin Hadad porte-parole du groupe
Renaissance mais on évoquera aussi avec
lui l'actualité internationale
évidemment notamment ce chantage de
Victor Orban sur l'Ukraine lors du
Conseil européen ainsi que la situation
dans la bande de Gaza voilà pour le
sommaire c'est parti pour ça vous
[Musique]
regarde c'est sans doute le principal
écueil encore aujourd'hui de la voiture
électrique son prix comment rendre ces
véhicules propres accessibles à tous
pour accélérer la transition écologique
Emmanuel Macron a-t-il trouvé enfin la
solution avec ce dispositif de leasing à
100 € par mois on en débat ce soir avec
nos invités bonsoir à tous les quatre
pierre caseneu vous êtes député
Renaissance porte-parole du groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale Léa Falco alors
les habitués de Ça vous regarde vous
connaissent bien vous êtes chroniqueuse
le vendredi d'habitude aujourd'hui vous
êtes là pour débattre en tant que
militante
écologiste sachant que vous participez
aussi à la formation d'acteur public ou
privé dans la transition écologique
Guillaume Guichard bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste aucho et vous êtes en charge
au sein du journal de tout le secteur
automobile enfin Yve Cara bonsoir vous
êtes porte-parole de mobilité Club
France qui était plus connu avant sous
le nom de Automobile Club mais pour
commencer on accueille thbao Enoc pour
son billet soyons clair prenez place
thibo installez-vous bonsoir Clément
bonsoir à tous bonsoir à vous Tib alors
expliquez-nous ce dispositif de leasing
à 100 € par mois ou c'est un peu le
cadeau de N du président la bonne
nouvelle de fin d'année pendant que la
la première ministre est empêtrée dans
les négociations sur la loi immigration
et bien Emmanuel Macron a sorti le ruban
les ficelles et le papier cadeau pour
lancer cette vidéo hier bien impactée
sur les réseaux sociaux une vidéo en
mode selfie regardez j'en avais pris
l'engagement pendant la campagne
présidentielle en 2022 je voulais vous
annoncer qu'à partir du 1er janvier va
être mise en place le système de leasing
à 100 € par mois le nom de la plateforme
ce sera
monleasingelectrique.gouf.fr vous y
allez vous regardez et vous serez
peut-être parmi les premiers Français à
avoir accès à ce leasing alors voilà une
mesure concrète positive écologique une
mesure qui coche toutes les cases voilà
qui explique que le président ce soir a
réservé la primeure de cette annonce ça
et peut-être aussi sa passion pour le
sujet on est attaché à la bagnole on
aime la bagnole et moi je l'adore voilà
la bagnole une passion présidentielle
est ce qui explique aussi qu'Emmanuel
Macron est repris le volant sur cette
mesure car elle faisait en réalité du
sur place ces derniers mois bloqué au
feu rouge de plusieurs ministères
écologie Matignon économie qui n'étit
pas d'accord sur les contours du
dispositif regardez ce dispositif
d'ailleurs il devait être initialement
lancé au mois de novembre c'est ce
qu'avait annoncé Bruno Le Maire du
retard a été pris le président sans n
agacer du coup il a mis le pied sur
l'accélérateur et ça y est le site est
enfin en ligne aujourd'hui Clément alors
justement comment est-ce que ça va se
passer est-ce que tout le monde y aura
droit non le dispositif est limité très
limité he même on parle de leasing
social belle formule de communication
pour c'est mieux que voiture de location
à longue durée pour les ménages modestes
ménages même très modestes he regardez
les conditions d'éligibilité 15400 € de
revenus fiscal maximum c'est environ le
SMIC et puis il faudra travailler être à
un gros rouleur 15 km entre votre
domicile et votre travail ou alors 8000
km de déplacement professionnels par an
des contours strict donc ce qui fait que
et bien ce dispositif sera limité à 20 à
30000 dossiers pour la première année
Clément ne partez donc pas au prix au
plancher si on respecte toutes ces
conditions comment ça se passe après
alors vous pouvez dès à présent aller
sur le site du ministère de l'écologie
pour tester votre éligibilité pour
déposer un dossier il faudra attendre
quelques jours mais en attendant vous
pouvez rêver regarder le ministère a mis
en ligne une belle plaquette commerciale
avec la liste des véhicules éligibles
listes non exhaustives où sont surtout
mises en avant les modèles français
alors attention he tous ces modèles ne
sont pas à 100 € par mois il y a un
piège le gouvernement a demandé au
constructeur au moins un modèle à ce
prix ou en dessous il faudra plutôt
compter 150 € pour la Mégane ou 140 €
pour une Citroën C4 le modèle le moins
cher ce devrait être la petite Twingo
électrique à 40 € par mois autant
d'offres financé par l'État à hauteur de
13000 € maximum dernière précision utile
pour être éligible ces voitures devront
avoir été construites en France ou dans
l'Union européenne et c'est d'ailleurs
le cas aussi pour les voitures qui
seront éliggible au bonus écologique
l'an prochain adieu les véhicules
fabriqués en Chine et adieu par la même
occasion la la petite Dacia spring l'une
des voitures électriques préférées des
Français alors voilà Clément vous savez
tout je vous laisse débattre avec vos
invités moi j'ai fait mon mon travail de
de vendeur automobile je vais aller
toucher ma commission excellent vendeur
Merci à VOUS thbaau Enoc on a maintenant
tous les éléments en main pour pour
débattre de sujet on commence par vous
la Falco quand vous voyez ce dispositif
de leasing qui est associé à un nouveau
bonus écologique est-ce que vous pensez
contient enfin la solution pour
démocratiser la voiture électrique pour
la rendre accessible au plus grand
nombre alors déjà il y a pas il y a pas
la solution c'est ça le problème
unee de la solu par y a deux choses
intéressantes qume alors d'une part
effectiv le fait que ce soit
relativement accessible même si les 40 €
c'est que la voiture donc il y a un
surcou associé dont on va certainement
parler mais qui reste sous le prix
mensuel pour l'utilisation d'une voiture
thermique pour les ménages auxquels ça
va être destiné cette mesure là donc
c'est intéressant de viser que ce soit
une mesure visée le deuxème point et là
en voyant les voitures c'est une vraie
réflexion
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour fabriquer
des petites voitures électriques en
Europe le futur de la mobilité
individuelle il y a un relatif consensus
là-dessus c'est la petite voiture
électrique parce qu'elle est efficace
parce que il y a de fait moins de
matière inutile inerte dans la voiture
et donc il faut que nos constructeurs
français en particulier européens aussi
puissent vraiment aller sur ce segment
là aujourd'hui ils ne le font pas à part
effectivement là c'est un moyen
d'encourager la production de petits
modèles priori passer par un leasing
c'est des subventions direct pour ces
petits modèles là donc il faut que le le
l'industrie des constructeurs le Prenn
au vol et vous l'avez dit dans
l'introduction c'est c'est une mesure
qui a été relativement débatue qui
faisait pas du tout l'unanimité chez les
constructeur donc il faut qu'on arrive à
que ce soit un signal clair qui est en
plus même pas un signal faible he un
signal clair sur le fait que il faut
développer ce segment-l dans les
prochaines années et ne plus aller sur
les segments sur lesquels aujourd'hui
l'industrie automobile marge
c'est-à-dire notamment le segment C les
les plus gros modè lourd quoi ifvkara
vous représentez un peu les intérêts des
automobilistes hein vous êtes
porte-parole d'une association
d'automobilistes souvent ce qu'on entend
dans la bouche des automobilistes comme
critique sur la voiture électrique c'est
son prix est-ce que là ça répond à la
critique essentielle qui est faite du
côté des automobilistes en général dir
que la rétissance pour l'électrique
c'est le prix bien évidemment mais c'est
l'autonomie et surtout la recharge c'est
c'est plus ça en fait qui freine le prix
s'il y avait un gros marché de
l'occasion bon on pourrait se
débrouiller avec une batterie qui
perdrait de de la recharge au fil des
années mais bon mais par contre elle est
pas polyvalente les petites voitures euh
qui sont des des petites citadines elles
ont une capacité de vitesse de recharge
très faible on peut pas faire des grands
trajets avec c'est pas vrai c'est pas
vrai il faut le dire on peut tourner
autour de chez soi on peut faire des
petits trajets au quotidien mais c'est
pas une voiture est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qu'on pourra faire à terme avec
les voitures électriques ou est-ce qu'il
faut pas renoncer à à cette dimension là
liée liée au au transport automobile non
mais on peut tout faire avec une une
électrique moi j'ai même connu quelqu'un
qui a fait un Paris île de Lyon avec une
Zoé voyez en sans payer de recharge je
vous assure j'ai discuté avec parce que
j'ai vu une Zoé à l'île de Lyon
immatriculé Paris je me suis dit comment
il a fait il a pas pris l'autoroute il a
pris que des petites routes il a mis de
jours voilà avec ses enfants donc il a
dormi à l'hôtel donc il y a aussi le
prix de l'hôtel voyez et il a pas payé
ses recharges parce qu'il était que sur
des recharges gratuites tout est
possible mais est-ce que c'est viable
est-ce que pour pour une vie de famille
ou une vie simplement par rapport à la
société qui s'estorganisé c'est viable
donc c'est toujours possible mais je
suis pas tellement d'accord sur l'avenir
qui ne sera que des petites voitures
électriques parce qu'il y a des besoins
qui sont autres notamment pour des
grandes familles je je précise aussi que
là on parle de trajet du quotidien parce
qu'on parle quand même de famille là sur
le sur les revenus fiscaux qu'on a vu
c'est pas des gens qui ont les moyens de
beaucoup partir en vacances ça c'est
malheureux mais c'est un vrai sujet et
donc il y a la question aussi de pouvoir
économiser sur le budget mobilité du
quotidien qui sont directement liés au
travail pour pouvoir aussi utiliser ce
budget libéré pour d'autres activités et
je trouve que c'est important et un
petit peu fallacieux de présenter la
voiture électrique ou les petites
voitures comme n'étant pas efficace dans
tous les segments
évidment
il y a des plus grosses voitures qui
sont proposées aussi he on les a pas
montré c'est elles sont elles sont plus
cheres mais elles s'adressent pas non
plus exactement au même public ouais
mais justement le public à quielle
s'adresse pourra peut-être pas se le
payer et il faut vraiment avoir l'idée
d'une voiture polyvalente dire quand on
a des petits moyens on peut pas avoir
deux voitures une électrique une
thermique aujourd'hui c'est le cas quand
on a une voiture électrique et on peut
le regretter hein Tesla mise à part
d'ailleurs parce qu'on peut faire des
grands trajets avec une Tesla avec les
autres voitures c'est plus compliqué et
il faut une voiture polyvalente et les
petites voitures électriques qui vont
s'adresser à ce public là ont besoin
d'une voiture polyvalente cette voiture
ce modèle il existe aujourd'hui ou
polyvalente à un prix abordable oui à un
prix abordable non non pas encore donc
ça veut dire que cette transition pour
vous elle est allée trop vite oui tout à
fait non mais je pardon parce que ça je
suis pas sûr que ce soit factuellement
vrai dans la proposition qui est faite
hein c'est c'est une c'est un spectre de
voitures qui vont effectivement de la
petite Twingo à 40 mais vous avez la
2008 qui va être à 150 la Méane à 150
bon heureusement qu'il y a pas que les
Tesla pour pouvoir partir long traj il
qu même modèle Tesla qui est éligible au
bonus écologique je crois oua tout à
fait euh au bonus écologique oui pas au
leasing euh pierre casen pour l'instant
cet accès au au bonus au leasing social
est est très limité on parle de 20 à
25000 voitures pour l'année prochaine
peut-être autour de 40000 en
2025 on peut vraiment rendre la la
voiture électrique populaire et et
accessible à tous avec des quotas aussi
bas alors c'est pas vraiment des quotas
en tant que tel c'estàd qu'il y a pas
une limite fixée par le gouvernement en
disant il y aura 20000 voitures cette
année et il y a des crédits pour les
subventions qui vont les crédits pour
les subventions ils sont déjà présents
c'est pas une question d'Argence pour ce
coupl très important c'est surtout une
question de disponibilité du parc parce
que voilà on prend une partie des
véhicules qui sont produits qui ont été
destinés directement à la vente par
exemple donc du coup l'idée c'est que la
limitation actuelle des 25000 sur la
première année c'est la disponibilité
des véhicules et de la production des
usines bien sûr on va monter en
puissance vous avez dit c'est 40000 qui
visent dès l'année prochaine enin dès
l'année 2025 et fin du quen 100000 donc
2027 100000
véhicules000 Moné en puissance
extrêmement rapide et extrêmement
extrêmement efficace quand encore une
fois on le sait euh pour les pour les
ménages qui sont concernés là sur les du
coup les 50 % des ménages les plus
modestes le taux de rotation c'est
environ 100000 véhicules neuf par an
enfin achetés par an d'occasion ou neuf
donc d'ici à 2027 l'idée est d'être
capable de répondre à la demande totale
du de nombre de de nouveaux véhicules
pour les 50 % des Français les plus
modèes c'est viable c'est viable
financièrement parce que il faut il y a
ce chiffre qui circule de 13000 €
jusqu'à 13000 € de subvention publique
par véhicule il faut ça c'est pour ça
que j'ai entendu au début de votre
chronique l'idée que c'était un coout
marketing ce n'est pas un coout
marketing c'éit une question posée
extrêmement fort de l'État à la fois un
effort financier vous l'avez dit 13000 €
par voiture 25 20000 voitures la
première année je vous fais le package à
250 millions pour la première année et
qui va effectivement monter en puissance
100000 on est 1liard 3 par an exact
vtion on assume très clairement que une
des priorités évidemment du président de
la République du gouvernement et de la
majorité c'est notre transition
écologique et énergétique que le la
transition vers des véhicules
électriques fait partie de cette
transition et donc on met les moyens
pour y arriver donc c'est pas un effet
marketing c'est une annonce qui est
vraiment extrêmement puissante et que je
salue évidemment parce que c'est encore
une fois ça va changer le quotidien des
gens ça va nous permettre d'accélérer
encore une fois ça a été très bien dit
c'est ciblé je pense que bonne mesure
encore plus une bonne mesure écologique
elle est efficace quand elle est ciblée
quand elle s'adresse à un public qui
effectivement de par cette barrière prix
aurait eu plus de mal à passer à un
véhicule électrique là on est à la fois
bon pour le portefeuille et donc le
pouvoir d'achat et à la fois bon pour le
climat et donc je pense qu'on est
vraiment dans une très bonne politique
publique et c'est je l'attendais depuis
très longtemps le président a eu raison
de taper du PO sur la table pour que ça
arrive sous le sapin Guillaume Guichard
Pier casen évoqué un problème de
disponibilité on fabrique pas encore
suffisamment de de voit ure citadine on
va dire pour répondre à la demande c'est
comme ça qui justifie le fait que il n'y
aura que 20000 véhicules en leasing
social l'année prochaine vous confirmez
je suis pas sûr que ce soit le la raison
vraiment pour laquelle on a'ura que
20000 voitures c'est quelle est la
raison selon vous moi je mettrai plutôt
la la raison sur le côté budgétaire de
l'État mais bon sachant que en plus
l'année prochaine l'année prochaine vous
aurez lycée 3 de Citroën qui sera vendu
sans bonus enfin prix sans bonus aucun à
23300 € ils vont en vendre énormément va
être produite en Slovaquie il y a une
usine pour ça donc elle respecte les
règles du bonus écologique de produ en
l'Union européenne donc le fond du
problème il est pas là pour vous Twingo
elle est produite en Slovénie enfin je
pense que les volume peut être là après
une question il y a la cannibalisation
avec la vente en direct des véhicules je
veux dire toute la demande toute l'offre
de véhiculle électrique ne va pas être
destinée au leasing encore une fois ça
c'est l'arbitrage aussi des
concessionnaires et donc pour le coup je
je suis confiant dans ce que je vous dis
et même certains c'estàdire que c'est
vraiment aujourd'hui la disponibilité du
parc qui fait que sur la montée en
puissance de 25000 cette année pour
arriver à 2020 à 100000 en 2027 c'est
avant tout une question de disponibilité
des véhicules bon vous êtes pas d'accord
sur ce point moi j'ai une question pour
vous quand même on a vu au tout début
quand Emmanuel Macron avait fait cette
annonce des constructeurs français dire
100 € par mois je pas sûr qu'on arrive à
descendre à ce prix et là on voit
aujourd'hui qu'il propose des modèles à
50 € par mois qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
entre les deux ass tout non en fait
effectivement durant toute la phase
préparatoire de la mesure les taux
d'intérêt ont grimpé au plafond enfin
par rapport à ce quiétait au moment où
la mesure avait été présente é comme une
promesse
électorale ensuite les prix des voitures
ont pas baissé l'année dernière au
contraire ils ont augmenté le prix des
du lithium et cetera a augmenté là ils
commencec à redescendre aussi donc fin
et puis les taux les taux d'intérêt
commenc aussi à se stabiliser donc on
s'aperçoit finalement que
l'environnement économique est un peu
plus comment dire favorable à ce genre
de mesure en tout cas estce que ça
rendre possible que des voitures c'est
c'est c'est le le for tau de subvention
qui permet ça aujourd'hui for tau de
subvention effectivement c'est deux fois
quasiment le bonus écologique que l'on
connaî il y a aussi un effet intéressant
je trouve de cette mesure c'est qu'il y
a eu un effet d'entraînement sur le
marché le marché c'estàd que des des
constructeurs proposent alors ils sont
plutôt chinois mais depuis le début
d'années il propos des voitures
électriques à 100 €. euh on a aussi
maintenant des constructeurs européens
qui proposent des voitures électriques à
100 € hors du dispositif donc ça a
stimulé un peu tout le monde ça a
stimulé et en fait ça arrive à un moment
aussi où on va voir arriver des petits
modèles sur électrique sur le marché je
parlais de lycée 3 de Citroën qui va
être donc la première voiture européenne
à moins de 25000 € qui un peu le gral la
voiture électrique à moins de 25000 €
c'est visée par Volkswagen par Renault
par Citroën par C lentis en général la
première ce sera bon bah ils sont aller
plus vite Citroën mais on va en voir
arriver d'autres le marché est en train
d'atteindre une forme de maturité c'est
ça et puis surtout aujourd'hui la
voiture électrique c'est 14 % du marché
européen l'année prochaine la CEA c'est
l'association des constructeurs
européens planche plutôt sur 20 % du
marché parce que justement ces petites
voitures citadines elles arrivent sur le
marché elles sont beaucoup moins chèes
que celles qui avaent aujourd'hui qui
sont encore aujourd'hui sur le marché
donc
je pense qu'on va vers une extension que
la mesure arrive aussi à un moment où la
voiture électrique deviendra un peu plus
mainstream même si on reste qu'à entre
guillemets sur le marché européen 20 %
Ifara je sais pas si vous êtes en mesure
de répondre à cette question mais on dit
souvent que les les constructeurs
européens et notamment les constructeurs
français avaient misé sur les grosses
berlines électrique parce que bah il les
vendait plus cher et il faisait plus de
marges dessus est-ce que oui mais si
pardon mais s'ils avaient besoin de
faire des marges c'est parce qu'ils
avaient besoin d'investir énormément
pour l'électrique que les petites
voitures étai des pas rentables à
fabriquer en Europe c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs toutes les petites voitures
sont sorties quasiment des catalogues
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que les prix
des voitur même thermique même thermique
c'est pour ça que les les les voitures
ont pris 30 % en uve les voitures neuv
en 4 5 an pris 30 % les voitures
d'occasion aussi mais je voudrais quand
même donner quelques précisions sur le
leasing si vous le permettez vraiment
pour nos téléspectate façon concrète
techniquement sur leasing ça va
s'adresser au gros rouleurs mais habité
à 15 km de son domicile effectiv 8000 km
pour pour un trajet je te hein c'est ou
c'est c'est vous habitez plus de 15 K
30 km par an 30 km par jour pardon sur 5
jours 150 vous êtes pas au 8000 il y a
les deux conditions qui
sont la mesure audelà de 8000 c'est
plutôt viser les indépendants ce qui
aussi on le sait une catégorie qui
utilise beaucoup Vic donc qu' fa aider
bienû mais ce que veux dire c'est pas du
tout une critique c'est c'est la
technique non c'est pas du tout une
critique un leasing en général il est
limité à 10000 km par an le leasing à
peu près là je crois que c'est 12000
c'est ça ce sera 12000 12000 12000 km et
ben ça c'est pas mal ça c'est une bonne
chose maintenant il faudra faire
attention au frais de restitution dans 3
ans s'ils prennent pas la voiture qui va
aller payer ces frais de restitution
l'État ou ou le possesseur de la
voiture les frais de restitution de
restition de remise en état de la
voiture parce que si vous arvez ce qui
est précisé de manière très certaine
c'est que si vous voulez rompre votre
contrat au bout de 3 ans c'est sans
frais il y a pas de frais de restitution
qui est
demandé il aura pas de frais de
restitution la voiture est end a des
frais quelque part qui doivent être
réglés quel que soit l'état de la
voiture ah bah j'imagine que s'il faut
avoir un certain nombre de R voiture ne
marche plus de toute façon oui
effectivement vous allez voir si gauche
a été en Bouti oui si vous permettez
parce que une grayure un un siège abîmé
un tapis abîmé un pare-choc abîmé ce qui
arrive quand même beaucoup dans les
villes ça coûte très très cher en fra de
restitution et là s'il disent écoutez
monsieur on prend la voiture mais elle
elle est au elle est abîmée au-delà de
de l'usage vous payez et ça peut jusqu'à
1000 ou 2000 € voire 3000 € à la remise
en état enfin c'est concret ça ce que je
dis hein on est d'accord donc qui va
payer ses frais de restitution s'il y en
a à la fin de ces 3 ans c'est moi je
suis utilis je sair ce qui est certain
pardon je vais reprendre uneexlication
si vous avez vous pouvez souscrire déjà
à une à une complémentaire on va dire de
d'entretien donc qui vous permet de
couvrir cetteou parce l'retien n pas
comprisement ni l'entretien ni
l'assurance parur alors l'entretien des
voitur électriqu en même temps coûte
moins cher que celui des voitures TER et
donc ça on y reviendra donc après ça ne
change pas comme dans un leasing
classique une mise en location classique
si vous cartonnez votre bagnole
effectivement vous devez la réparer
avant de pouvoir la rendre sur la
restitution donc ça fait pas partie
entre guillemets du pas de frais de
résiliation du contrat quoi c'est pas de
la réparation c'est de la remise en état
non mais l' ça pe coûter très très cher
je connais bien le sujet ça peut coûter
cher à la fin alors on va prendre juste
un peu plus de hauteur avec vous Falco
sur ce leasing à 100 € par mois on reste
sur le principe de du modèle de la
voiture
individuelle on peut mener la transition
écologique en restant sur ce modèle là B
enfin bien sûr enfin ça fait
partie de la solution encore une fois
sur la mobilité la mobilité à l'échelle
globale on va avoir ut c'est ça pour
tout un tas de gens qui ne pourront pas
se passer de la voiture jamais parce
qu'ils habitent dans des zones qui sont
mal desservies qui ne pourront pas être
déservies par les transpars commun qui
ne pourront pas être desservis par les
mobilités douces qu'ils exercent un
certain nombre de métiers qui fait
qu'ils ont besoin d'avoir une
disponibilité qu'il soient médecin
pompiers et cetera qu'ils a une famille
nombreuse il y a des cas qui ne pourront
pas être assurés de déplacement
autrement que mais idée n'est pas que
tout le monde ait une voiture électrique
la question c'est que est-ce que on
remplace effectivement les voitures
thermiques par des voitures électriques
à un pour un la réponse est très
probable non et c'est pour ça que par
ailleurs il y a plein de il y a plein
d'infrastructures qu'il va falloir
construire en terme de mobilité douce en
terme de mobilité partagée et ça ça se
joue sur les territoires maintenant
c'est très bien effectivement que on est
pour les populations qui ne pourront pas
s'en passer demain et qui ne peuvent pas
s'en passer aujourd'hui une alternative
électrique pour les extraire du réseau
de dépendance de la voiture thermique
parce que quand on parle de viabilité
financière il y a d'un côté les
utilisateurs pour qui de toute évidence
ça va être moins cher d'avoir une
voiture électrique en leasing que
d'avoir un véhicule thermique
aujourd'hui notamment avec le prix de
l'essence qu'on voit avec des assurances
qui sont peut-être un peu plus faibles
mais qui compensent pas ce différentiel
donc c'est plus intéressant pour le pour
l'usager pour le le le le conducteur et
de l'autre côté il y a les finances
publiques et en terme de finances
publiques effectivement ça peut paraître
un montant qui est très élevé hein 13000
sauf que quand vous regardez avec le
prix qu'on supporte de la voiture
thermique du modèle de la voiture
thermique on a quand même un bouclier
tarifffaire qui a été mis en place et
qui pour le coup n'était pas ciblé vous
en parliez mais le le bouclier tarifaire
était pas ciblé ce qui voula dire que
les gens qui n'avaient pas d'autre choix
que de prendre la voiture et les gens
qui prenaient la voiture alors qu'ils
avaient d'autres options avaient le le
même prix bon ça c'est quelque chose
mais il a coûté 40 milliards quand même
de tête il me semble hein ce bouclier 40
milliards c'est énorme s'extraire de ces
réseaux de dépendance et permettre aux
gens de s'en extraire ça c'est un vrai
vrai enjeu et sur lequel je pense que
cette mesure va aider h alors il faut
aussi que la tendance suive euh il faut
que ces voitures on puisse les recharger
euh quand on est au SMIC bah on n' pas
forcément un garage pour euh garer sa
voiture donc pour la protéger bah des
dégradations euh au quotidien et on n'
pas forcément une bande de recharge
électrique euh le gouvernement s'est
penché sur la question sur le fait de
bah de développer d'accélérer le
développement des bordnes de recharge
publiqu alors sur ce je vais vous
répondre sur ce pointl je pense c'est
très important le sujet qui vient d'être
évoqué pour dire effectivement que cette
disposition le leasing social cette
promesse tenue du président de la
République ça s'inscrit dans un une
stratégie beaucoup plus globale sur la
décarbonation de nos mobilités il juste
un point le transport c'est 30 % de nos
émissions de CO2 en France donc c'est
c'est le plus gros de tous les paquets
c'est et la voiture thermique c'est la
moitié et dedans la voiture thermique
c'est la moitié ce qu'on
fait on essaie d'électrifier le parc
c'est ce qu'on fait et on essaie
d'accélérer notamment avec ce lesing
social pour cibler les les ménages les
plus modestes mais on fait énormément de
choses à côté c'est le plan vélo 2
milliards c'est ce qu'on a lancé sur le
ROR métropolitain c'est tout ce que nous
faisons évidemment sur le le le le toute
la stratégie autour de de ces du
covoiturage et du report ce qu'on
appelle le report modal donc euh encore
une fois évidemment que la voiture
électrique c'est une part importante de
la solution on peut pas s'en passer la
petite voiture électrique de demain fait
partie intégrante de not solution mais
il y a aussi la volonté effectivement de
privilégier aussi les autres moyens de
transport le transport collectif que ce
soit le bus que ce soit le covoiturage
que ce soit le train que ce soit le vélo
ça c'est très très important à avoir en
tête et on met beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'investissements là-dedans sur
le plan recharge on est dans les clous
hein par rapport à notre à notre
dynamique au trajectoires qu'on voulait
sur le déploiement des des des des des
des des bornes de recharge il y a
peut-être une évolution mais ça c'est
peut-être les spécialistes qui auront
plus cette impression là où on est parti
peut-être au début sur la voiture
électrique avec le my du pavillon avec
une borne de recharge par personne et
aujourd'hui on voit qu'effectivement
avec le le déploiement des voitures
électriques dans des zones beaucoup plus
urbaines avec des gens qui ont moins de
d'habitat individuels se développent
plutôt ces stations service de
l'électrique avec des des des des
modèles encore une fois de recharge qui
changent et donc on a aussi ce challenge
là de Maya partout sur le territoire sur
évidemment toutes nos aires d'autoroute
parce que oui il y a des voitures
électriques sur nos autoroutes et
heureusement on peut aller en vacances
au voitures électrique donc voilà en
tout cas cette stratégie là elle est on
est dans les clous et le déploiement des
bornes électriques en France aujourd'hui
est sur bon rail la France est en retard
là-dessus vous
on a franchi alors non non on a franchi
avec retard par contre c'est vrai la
borne des 100000 bornes justement bon
électrique maintenant c'est parti ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'on voit
énormément de de startup de même de
groupes plus gros qui s mettre parce que
c'est c'est ça intéresse beaucoup aussi
les les les les financiers c'est des
c'est c'est des c'est des dé
placacements intéressants en fait euh et
puis même les les supermarchés par
exemple hein ça va être un nouveau
produit d'appel aujourd'hui la prodie
d'appel c'est la c'est le prix à la
pompe ça c'est la enfin cétait parce que
maintenant c'est plus chez eux qu'on
trouve le moins cher mais bon euh donc
le produit d'appel demain ce sera les
bandnes électriques sur le parking de
Lidl par exemple ou d'un autre et donc
on rechargera sa voiture dès qu'on se
garera on ira faire les courses on
recharge bon ça résout une partie du
problème aussi de pas avoir de bnes chez
soir hein trouver
au final de plus en plus partout sur les
parkings et CETA alors pour les bandes
de recharge pour notamment pour les
autoroutes parce que c'est l'itinérance
l'enjeu avec les voiture électrique hein
c'est pas à lamite de tourner autour de
chez soi pour le quotidien il y a quand
même un vrai problème en France et moi
je parle je passe tout l'été sur
l'autoroute donc je connais bien le
problème c'est que à peu près les 2
tiers des je suis pas contre attention
c'est pas du tout contre c'est c'est un
fait on va dire même les 3/4 des bornes
de recharge électrique aujourd'hui ce
sont des étrangers qui traversent la
France donc va falloir surdim pour qu'on
puisse être traversé sinon il va avoir
un gros problème je sais pas comment il
va être résolu mais ça c'est un vra je
sais pas ce que P après le le la
réglementation sur les les les bornes de
recharge sur les aires d'autoroute elle
est claire en gros il faut que soit
dimensionné pour les pics d'été donc en
gros ça va être surdimensionné pour
toutes les autres vacances et cetera
pour que on a moins de je sais plus je
sais plus quel est le nombre de voitures
mais en gros c'est dimensionné pour les
pics pour l'instant en tout cas on n pas
trop on n pas on est très très loin de
la surdimension en tout cas il y a pas
de que un mot quand même de ce nouveau
bonus écologique qui est désormais
réservé aux voitures électriques qui
sont produites au sein de l'Union
européenne ça c'était la condition fixée
par les constructeurs français et
européens pour jouer le jeu du leasing
de la voiture électrique à 100 € par
mois parce que c'est clairement un moyen
bah de de rendre les les Chinois moins
moins compétitifs oui c'est sûr je sais
pas si c'est du donnant donnant hein
mais c'est sûr alors le bonus écologique
revisité enfin vous le direz peut-être
mais c'est que l'objectif c'est que le
CO2 émis lors de la construction de la
voiture soit pris en compte dans la
loocation de l'aide de la construction
et de l'acheminement oui oui tout à fait
le transport l'acheminement jusqu'au
marché ouais donc effectivement quelle
est la conséquence directe de ça c'est
d'exclure t les toutes les voitures
produites en Chine en Corée ou au Japon
est ce qui laisse le champ libre au
constructeurs européens et français
notamment pour les voitures électriques
pierre casen d'un mot on avait entendu
Carlos tavarz comment dire avoir un
échange assez vif avec Bruno Lemer sur
le fait qu'il disait qu'il ne pouvait
pas fabriquer en France des petites
citadines quand Bruno Le Maire lui lui
disait il faut relocaliser en France euh
est-ce que là euh avec ce bonus
écologique revisité vous pensez que il
est envisageable pour stellantis de de
revoir sa position je le pense B déjà
effectivement on est en train de créer
on est en train de de créer l'offre on a
créer la demande pardon derrière de
manière évidente euh la raison pour
laquelle effectivement le critère euh
climat c'est pas tant sur le transport
en tant que tel de la voiture on
pourrait penser instinctivement que
c'est parce que c'est le trajet entre la
Chine et la France qui fait la
différence c'est sur surtout sur la
manière dont est produite la voiture
parce queon profite aussi d'un mix
énergétique extrêmement décarboné en
France grâce à notre parc nucléaire on
va on va justement en
parler on va se pencher en détail sur
cette question tout de suite avec un un
sujet de Stéphanie des piierr ce qui va
permettre d'ouvrir le débat sur le sujet
il s'agit de voir le vrai bilan carbone
de la voiture
électrique une voiture sur 100 est
électrique en France mais le virage est
pris en ville ou à la campagne en 2023
la France a battu un record pour la
première fois 20 % des véhicules vend du
neuf sont électrique selon l'agence pour
l'environnement la moitié des acheteurs
est motivé par la volonté de réduire son
empreinte carbone quand on voit son
ancienne voiture le matin qui fume comme
pas possible et qui pollue comme pas
possible l'électrique pour moi c'était
le meilleur choix pour pour
l'environnement et puis d'un point de
vue pratique c'est la fabrication qui
pèse le plus lourd dans le bilan carbone
d'une voiture électrique par rapport au
thermiques sa construction émet en effet
deux fois plus de CO2 qu'une voiture
classique en cause la batterie et ses
composant aluminium terre rare de 300 à
700 kg selon le modèle ces matériaux
sont incontournables cependant les
constructeurs promettent d'utiliser
bientôt des énergies vertes pour faire
tourner leurs usines et limiter l'impact
environnemental de l'électrique il y a
encore une dette carbone bien sûr mais
il y a une dynamique qui fait que cette
dette carbone on a comme on a comme ob
objectif par rapport aux accords de
Paris qu'elle disparaissent àhizon 2050
c'est veut dire que que toutes les
voitures qu'on va fabriquer à partir de
50 mais mais pour dit bien avant seront
neutres en carbone dans le match
électrique thermique ce qui compte aussi
c'est le poids du véhicule pour effacer
la dette carbone de sa construction il
faut choisir une voiture électrique de
petite taille donc avec une petite
batterie finalement laad préconise de
choisir une batterie juste adapté à
l'usage le plus fréquent c'està-dire
l'usage majoritaire du véhicule
typiquement le trajet domicile travail
du du quotidien et non pas à l'usage le
plus contraignant comme les départs en
vacances le problème de la voiture
électrique c'est aussi le recyclage pour
cette citeadine accidenté le garagiste
doit retirer la batterie 300 kg de
matière dont seulement une partie est
recyclable elle va partir chez un
recycleur qui lui doit au moins
aujourd'hui la recycler à plus de 55 %
et dans les mois et années qui viennent
à plus de 75 %
matières premières construction
recyclage la voiture électrique a encore
de gros progrès à faire pour réduire son
empreinte
carbone voilà donc pour ce reportage de
Stéphanie despierr avec nos confrères de
France Télévision pierre caseneu en quoi
le fait de fabriquer ces voitures dans
le sein de l'Union européenne permet de
réduire leur bilan carbone je l'ai dit
sur juste avant le le reportage sur
évidemment le mix électrique que nous on
a en France mais on est capable je
reprends le le sujet sur est-ce qu'on
est capable de le faire en France il y a
3 an tout le monde disait c'est
impossible de construire des batteries
électriques en France le coup de la main
d'œ tout ce que vous voulez le président
a décidé d'en faire une priorité on en
est à la troisème usine qui va sortir
dans la batterie vallée qu'on est en
train de faire entre le pcalé d'un
kerque et et et d'un kerque dans le Lord
pour le coup on est capable de produire
aujourd'hui des batteries avec ces
fameuses giga Factory on est en train de
créer cette fili cette filière là c'est
extrêmement importante et là encore on
va réussir à tirer vers le bas
effectivement le coût écologique des
véhicules et donc avoir des véhicules
électriques et il y aura toujours autant
de terr RAR autant de méto RAR dans ces
voit change effectivement ça change pas
sur l'approvisionnement en en matière
première mais sur la conception du
véhicule qui est là aussi extrêmement
polluante on va évidemment tirer vers le
bas énormément le bilan énerg ENF le
bilan carbone pardon de la production du
véhicule tel est aujourd'hui Léa Falco
il y a un sujet quand même dont on parle
un peu là dans dans dans le
reportage que faire de ces batteries
électrique enfin c'est quand même un
problème ouais ouais il y a plusieurs
sujets alors il y a le sujet du poids
qui a été évoqué donc comme la batterie
est plus lourde c'est pour ça qu'il y a
aussi un vrai intérêt à faire des des
véhicules plus légers globalement parce
qu'ils vont être un peu plus lourds
qu'un thermique équivalent alors donc il
y a ce Pol il y a la question des
matériaux effectivement la voiture
électrique prend des matériaux alors
sinon rares au moins au moins
relativement précieux qui va falloir
recycler et puis sur cette question là
il y a il y a deux choses il y a le
recyclage alors avec des filières qui
sont pas encore tout à fait constituées
sur le lithium on a encore aujourd'hui
des des sommes qui sont un peu trop
faibles pour avoir des réseaux vraiment
organisés qui devraent être par ailleurs
à l'échelle européenne donc qui a une
vraie question là de comment est-ce
qu'on va structurer ces réseaux de
recyclage qui vont on sait aujourd'hui
recycler une batterie là le on entendit
dans le reportage 55 % la batterie il y
a des question sur la batterie et sur
l'organisation générale de la voiture
c'estàd qu'aujourd'hui on a des voitures
mais comme nos téléphones par ailleurs
qui sont fait c'est ça qui sont pas
détachables et donc on a beaucoup de mal
dans la conception même et là c'est
plutôt côté constructeur qu'il faut
aller se pencher sur la manière dont on
va pouvoir les démanteler et faire en
sorte d'organiser ces réseau là et et
juste sur l'impact de la voiture il faut
être très clair sur le fait que
aujourd'hui en analyse de cycle de vie
c'est-à-dire du début de la naissance de
la voiture à son recyclage une voiture
électrique émet deux fois moins qu'une
voiture thermique et c'est pour ça que
je vous parle aussi pour toutes ces
questions d'empreinte matière de ne pas
remplacer un à un mais de faire en sorte
de remplacer les voitures thermique
qu'on pourra pas éliminer de toute façon
par des voitures électriques et de
développer d'autres types de mobilité
par ailleurs donc pour vous juste le mot
de la fin il y a pas de doute c'est
quand même plus écolo de produire et de
rou pour moi c'est pour l'état de la
recherche he c'est pas moi qui dit c'est
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie je
me garderais bien de donner un autre
avis que celui-là très bien merci à tous
les quatre d'être venu débattre sur le
le plateau de Ça vous regarde dans un
instant notre grand témoin Benjamin
Hadad mais d'abord le menu des
chroniques de nos affranchis Mariette
darigrand nous parlera politique Airie
dans le mot de la semaine le choix de
Bertrand Perrier sera question de
transition de genre au collège ou au
lycée enfin la chronique Bourbon express
d'samand d'ingava de quoi allez-vous
nous parle Elsa j-3 avant la CMP la
commission mixte paritaire vous savez
celle chargée des lab un compromis sur
le projet de loi immigration et bien
c'est parfait à tout à l'heure tous les
trois notre grand invité ce soir
Benjamin Hadad donc porte parole du
groupe Renaissance à l'Assemblée ancien
chercheur en relations internationales
c'est lui qui a dirigé la délégation
parlementaire qui s'est rendue en Israël
il y a quelques semaines il est aussi en
première ligne sur le dossier ukrainien
et sur le soutien de l'Europe à
l'Ukraine son portrait est signé Marco
Pomier si on vous invite Benjamin Hadad
c'est pour avoir le regard du chercheur
spécialiste des relations
internationales sur ces deux pays en
guerre qui vous sont chers l'Ukraine et
Israël alors que tsal vient de récupérer
le corps d'un otage
franco-israélien enlevé par le Hamas
lors de son attaque sanglante du 7
octobre cette barbarie vous l'avez
constaté de vos propres yeux dans
l'équipe israéliens des images très très
dures de de maisons totalement brûlé
des témoignages de soldats qui ont
retrouvé de nombreux corps décapités
Benjamin Hadad votre engagement
politique est précoce des 18 ans d'abord
militant chez les jeunes de l'UMP
secrétaire national du Parti de 2011 à
2014 proche d'un certain Jean-François
Copé je voulais juste dire un petit mot
de génération France et génération
France Jeune que la plupart d'entre vous
connaissez qui est un f tank donc un
cercle de réflexion qui a été créé par
jean-françis cop depuis quelques années
pour promouvoir le débat des Fing tanks
il y en aura d'autres Benjamin Hadad ils
vous mèneront jusqu'à Washington et des
cercles de réflexions à l'hémicycle il
n'y a qu'un pas marcheur de la première
heure au côté d'Emmanuel Macron député
de Paris porte-parole du groupe
Renaissance européen convaincus
engagement fort en faveur de l'Ukraine
déjà en 2014 vous débarquz place Maidan
à Kief en plein soulèvement de la
population le tournant de votre
engagement dites-vous c'est la première
fois de l'histoire que des gens se font
cibler tuer parce qu'ils brandissent le
drapeau européen qui pour eux est la
promesse d'un meilleur avenir de la
démocratie de la lutte contre la
corruption et d'un avenir européen
l'avenir européen de l'Ukraine plus que
jamais d'actualité alors que l'Union
européenne a décidé hier l'ouverture des
négociations d'adhésion avec l'Ukraine
c'est une victoire pour l'Ukraine une
victoire pour toute l'Europe journée
historique et pourtant mitigée alors que
la Hongrie d'Orban a bloqué l'aide
européenne de 50 milliards d'euros pour
Kief l'aide américaine elle reste
suspendu à un accord du Congrès alors
Benjamin Hadad sans aide occidentale
massive êtes-vous pessimiste l'Ukraine
peut-elle encore gagner cette
guerre bonsoir Benjamin Adad alors je
rappelle que vous présidez le groupe
d'amitié franceukraine ici même à
l'Assemblée nationale on a vu Vladimir
Poutine qui est un peu fanfaronné dans
son discours annuel hier les
observateurs qui s'inquiètent de voir
l'armée russe progresser sur plusieurs
points de la ligne de front en Ukraine
et on voit donc que les robinets de
l'aide occidentale à l'Ukraine sont en
train de se refermer donc êtes-vous
inquiet je suis inquiet mais je suis pas
fataliste parce que le fatalisme c'est
un choix je l'entends ceux qui nous
disent que l'Ukraine peut pas gagner la
guerr sont les mêmes qui nous disaient
que Poutine n'attaquerait jamais sont
les mêmes qui nous disaient que les
Ukrainiens ne résisterait pas on a vu
depuis presque 2 ans maintenant les
Ukrainiens résister de façon héroïque
pour défendre le leur liberté leur
souveraineté leur avenir européen aussi
on a vu les Européens et les Américains
se mobiliser là aussi on pensait qu'on
se lasserait rapidement qu'on essaierait
de trouver un accord avec Vladimir
Poutine mais la guerre est pas terminée
et le test aujourd'hui c'est de tenir
dans le temps long parce que mais tenir
l'Ukraine peut-elle tenir sans l'aide
occidentale aujourd'hui on doit
continuer à se mobiliser pour l'Ukraine
on doit au niveau européen débloquer
l'aide on aura un nouveau sommet en
janvier puis il y a peut-être des
alternatives on pourra en parler il y a
des faç euré seul peut suffire parce que
on voit que côté américain c'est en
train l'a l'aide européenne l'aide
américaine tenir ensemble encore une
fois Vladimir Poutine il espérait que
l'Ukraine s'estffondit comme un château
de carte après le 24 février ce n'est
pas arrivé donc aujourd'hui son plan B
c'est d'attendre attendre qu'on se lasse
et qu'on se divise que en Europe les
intérêts nationaux égoïes de court terme
reprennent le dessus qu'aux États-Unis
peut-être demain il y ait l'élection
américaine avec Donald Trump ne lui
donnons pas cette victoire encore une
fois c'est un choix que nous devons
faire il y a pas de fatigue de l'Ukraine
dans les opinions publiques on le voit
au contraire les EUR euréens veulent que
l'Ukraine gagne cette guerre qu'elle
puisse se défendre donc continuons à à à
soutenir les Ukrainiens ça passera avec
la négociation de l'aide européenne qui
peut peut-être se faire d'une autre
façon de façon intergouvernementale on
l'avait fait au moment de la crise de
l'euro si après tout 26 États européens
sans la Hongrie se mettre d'accord pour
faire des aides bilatérales au
m il a se PLB par
exemple continuons aussi à interpeller
nos amis américains avec presque 150
parlementaires de toute l'Europe nous
avons adressé cette semaine une lettre
au Parlement interaméricain pour leur
expliquer l'importance de débloquer
l'aide à l'Ukraine et puis ce processus
européen il est si important c'est pour
ça que les Ukrainiens se battent meurent
depuis 2014 un drapeau européen au bras
parce que c'est pas seulement une
victoire territoriale qu'il recherche
c'est la liberté de pouvoir choisir leur
avenir d'être une démocratie libre
européenne membre de l'Union européenne
membre de l'OTAN et donc je crois que ce
qu'on a hierette question oui sur cette
question de la future adhésion en tout
cas de l'ouverture de négociation
d'adhésion de l'Ukraine à l'Union
européenne on a vu hier l'Union
européenne
débloquer un tiers environ des 30
milliards d'euros d'êes qui ont été
promis à la Hongrie de Victor Orban et
d'un coup au miracle Victor Orban a
renoncé à mettre son son véau au
processus d'adhésion ça ressemble quand
même à à une forme de chantage on peut
continuer longtemps comme ça avec Victor
Orban on voit Victor orbane qui va
contre les intérêts européens qui
utilise effectivement ces processus
comme une forme de chantage on voit une
dérive autoritaire de ce régime depuis
longtemps effectivement il faut se poser
la question de savoir si Victor orbane a
envie d'être européen envie d'êtred la
question de l'adhésion de la Hongrie du
maintien de la Hongrie dans l'Union
européenne se pose aujourd'hui c'est une
question que s'est posée à demi mot la
première ministre lettonne hier vous
êtes d'accord avec elle la question se
POS auourd'hui vous savez qu'
aujourd'hui dans les traités européens
de toute façon il y a pas de mécanisme
pour exclure c'est un pays mais là la
question se pose c'est que la Hongrie
d'une certaine façon est en train de
s'autoexclure aujourd'hui de l'Union
européenne à la fois sur les intérêt
partagé mais aussi sur les valeurs de
liberté de de droits de l'homme d'État
de droit de liberté de la presse et et
d'indépendance de la justice qui font de
notre union donc en effet c'est une
question qu'il faut qu'il faut se poser
au-delà des questions lié à l'état de
droit est-ce que la Hongrie aujourd'hui
est le cheval de troit de Vladimir
Poutine dans l'Union européenne vous
savez c'est Vladimir Poutine qui a
remercié Victor Orban d'avoir bloqué
l'aide de l'Union européenne à l'Ukraine
en disant qu'elle défendait ses intérêt
donc en effet il suffit de l'entendre de
la bouche de Vladimir Poutine lui-même
après moi je voudrais quand même voir le
vers à moitié plein tout de même de ce
qui s'est passé au sommet européen c'est
qu'on a pu trouver un accord pour ouvrir
ces négociations d'adhésion ce sera un
processus long l'Ukraine a encore
beaucoup de chemins à faire dans la
lutte contre la corruption dans l'État
de droit les réformes économiques il
faut le dire mais encore une fois les
Ukrainiens se battent pour être une
nation libre et européenne depuis 2014
il y a 10 ans déjà et la révolution de
la dignité de de la place Maidan on leur
doit ça et donc je pense que l'Ukraine
aujourd'hui défend l'Europe défend la
sécurité de l'Europe défend les valeurs
de l'Europe Europe et donc
accompagnons-les dans ce processus le
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron s'est beaucoup investi y compris
d'ailleurs dans un dialogue qui a été
parfois dur robuste avec Victor orbane
ces dernières semaines pour pouvoir
débloquer ces négociations d'adhésion la
France d'ailleurs avait amené certains
de ses partenaires à reconnaître la
candidature de l'Ukraine l'an dernier
après le 24 février donc continuons dans
cette voie derrière le cas Orban il y a
aussi la question de ce droit de vetto
que dont dispose chaque État membre de
l'Union européenne sur certains sujets
il faut réduire son champ d'application
pour éviter une forme de paralysie oui
je le crois mais au-delà de ça il faudra
poser la question de la réforme des
institutions en parallèle de
l'élargissement on a un processus
d'élargissement qui va qui qui est
inévitable qui est l'avenir de notre
continent pour la stabilité la paix de
notre continent aux Balcans occidentaux
à la Moldavie l'Ukraine la Géorgie aussi
qui a été reconnue comme candidate hier
encore une fois ce sera un processus
long en parallèle de cela il faudra
réformer les institutions pour avoir un
processus de décision plus rapide poser
la question par exemple effectivement de
la majorité qualifiée sur un certain
nombre de domaines peut-être réformer
les les aides structurelles euh avoir
des étaps pilotes dans certaines
politiques c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui
faire en sorte qu'on ait une Europe qui
puisse défendre ses intérêts assumer sa
puissance et euh intégrer des nouveaux
membres d'un mot sur ces élections
européennes qui approche il y a 5 ans
Emmanuel Macron avait mis en scène un
clivage entre progressiste d'un côté
nationaliste on a le sentiment que
depuis 2018 euh il y a une forme de
replili sur soi qui a gagné un peu tout
le monde y compris le camp des
progressistes est-ce que pour vous ce
clivage il vaut encore pour les
élections qui arrive dans quelques mois
les élections européennes elles vont
être l'occasion de poser une question
très simple on sera à un moment où
Donald Trump sera probablement le
candidat républicain en tête des
sondages aujourd'hui face à Joe Biden
celui qui avait lancé des guerres
protectionnistes contre l'Union
européenne et qui qualifie l'Union
européenne d'ennemi on aura peut-être
toujours une guerre d'agression contre
l'Ukraine une guerre à Gaza aussi
l'instabilité à nos frontièrees est-ce
qu'on veut une Europe divisée affaiblie
comme nous le proposent les populistes
d'extrrême gauche et d'extrême droite ou
est-ce qu'on veut au contraire une
Europe qui est capable sans naïveté de
défendre ses frontières de défendre ses
intérêts commerciaux sa souveraineté
technologique sa défense et de lutter
contre l'agression son continent c'est
cette question là et Renaissance la
majorité sera le seul bulletin
pro-européen le seul butin qui proposera
une Europe forte dans ce contexte
l'actualité internationale c'est aussi
cette guerre donc entre Israël et le et
le Hamas l'armée israélienne a donc
annoncé ce matin la mort d'un des trois
otages français Elia Toledano son corps
a été retrou ouvé lors d'une opération
menée par tal dans la bande de Gaza vous
aviez rencontré son frère je crois le 31
octobre dernier faisait partie des
proches d'otage qui avait été reçu à
l'Assemblée nationale j'imagine que vos
pensées vont ce soir pour sa famille
pour ses proches est-ce qu'on sait dans
quel circonstances IIa Toledano a été
tué non j'ai pas plus d'information on
sait qu'il a été pris en otage par le
Hamas après l'attaque barbare du du 7
octobre et effectivement c'est une
pensée de de condoléance de tristesse
aussi de colère que que j'adresse à à sa
famille ass ses proches euh c'est un
deuil pour nous français on a été aussi
deuillé par cette attaque du 7 octobre
40 français qui sont morts il y a des
des otages des des disparus il faut
continuer à se mobiliser pour la
libération des des derniers otages eu on
est on s'est rendu avec des collègues en
Israël quelques jours après l'attaque du
7 octobre pour exprimer notre solidarité
pour rencontrer ces familles françaises
illé aussi qui qui vivent un enfer qui
ont été séparés parfois d'enfants de
bébés de grands-parents de de frères
agresseur on les a reçu à plusieurs
reprises à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
d'ailleurs un engagement fort de la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale il y
a elbrun pivé de façon transpartisan il
faut continuer à se mobiliser et à
rappeler que ce sont nos familles aussi
qui ont été touché par cette barbarie
sur le conflit armé lui-même on voit que
le principal allié d'Israël les
États-Unis commence un peu à s'agacer du
décalage entre la façon dont israël
affirme vouloir épargner les civil dans
la bande de Gaza et le bilan humain sur
le sur le terrain Joe Biden parle
lui-même de Bombard ement indiscriminé
est-ce que vous reprendriez cette
expression de votre côté je crois que
vous savez c'est la position de la
France c'est de dire que Israël est en
guerre contre le Hamas qui un mouvement
terroriste qui a attaqué mais que cette
opération doit être menée avec des
trêves humanitaires avec le respect des
des de la protection de la vie des des
civils et du droit international
humanitaire aujourd'hui quand on entend
les dirigeants du Hamas ils persistent à
dire qu'ils veulent mener de nouvelles
attaques comme celle du 7 octobre contre
cont Israël donc pour les Israéliens
c'est une guerre existentielle
c'est-à-dire c'est d'empêcher le Hamas
de pouvoir mener d'autres attaques de ce
type il est possible de parce que
l'objectif affiché c'est éradiquer le
Hamas alors est-ce que est-ce que cet
objectif militaire est atteignable
est-ce que c'est pas un moyen de ne pas
se fixer d'objectif politique mais vous
vous avez raison de poser cette question
c'est la question qui a posé le
président de la République récemment
c'est-à-dire que toute opération
militaire doit être soumise à un
objectif politique et là l'objectif
politique ça doit être tout même la la
reconstruction d'une nouvelle gouver
ance dans la bande de Gaza parce que je
pense comme l'ont dit d'ailleurs les
Américains et l'administration Biden que
les réoccupations israéliennes est une
impasse revenir à la situation avant
2005 serait quand Israël occupait la
bande de Gaza avant le retrait d'Ariel
Charon serait serait une impasse et donc
réfléchir effectivement à une une
gouvernance qui peut mener après au
retour d'un processus politique et la
souveraineté des des palestinien une
solution à à deux états il n'y a pas
d'alternative à terme que la séparation
entre l'israëlen Palestiniens et la
souveraineté des des Palestiniens dans
la garantie de des sécurités de
l'existence d'Israël merci Benjamin
Hadad vous restez avec nous parce que
nous accueillons à présent nos
affranchis prenez siège installez-vous
Mariette darigrand Bertrand Perrier et
Elsa mondingava on commence avec vous
Elsa et votre chronique Bourbon Express
vous vous êtes penché sur les tensions
que suscite la loi immigration au sein
de la majorité oui et cette histoire
pourrait avoir un un titre le dilemme
d'éliisabeth born c'est un peu comme le
jeu des enfants tu préfères tu préfères
un accord avec la droite ou tu préfères
l'unité de ta majorité et bien c'est ce
qui se passe un peu clément pour la
première ministre ellisabeth borne tant
les lignes rouges des uns et des autres
semble difficilement compatible alors la
majorité elle cherche toujours un accord
le gouvernement y croit le président de
la République y croit il s'est exprimé
il y a quelques heures il y a un
gouvernement qui est au travail ministre
qui n'a pas ménagé sa peine
une majorité qui ne s'est jamais divisé
jamais sur ce texte comme sur les
précédents et c'est une grande force je
suis favorable à ce qu'un compromis
intelligent soit trouvé au service de
l'intérêt général et du pays et que il
nous permette d'avoir un texte qui
améliore notre fonctionnement commun et
permet de mieux protéger les Français
sauf que et bien dans la majorité
effectivement il y en a certains qui
commencent à s'inquiéter regardez ce que
me confia un conseiller ministériel tout
à l'heure est-ce qu'on a vraiment
intérêt à voir un texte si le prix à
payé c'est une explosion de la majorité
à trop concéd à la droite est-ce que
c'est dans ses propres rangs que
certaines voies dans la majorité
pourraient faire défaut si la question
par exemple des régularisations est
réduite à sa portion congrue ou si les
conditions d'attribution des allocations
par exemple sont durcies alors est-ce
qu'on a une idée justement bah des
rapports de force au sein de la majorité
non c'est très difficile à connaître et
on entend un petit peu tout et son
contraire je vous donne des exemples on
entend que le modem est vigilant on
entend que les anciens LR chez
Renaissance poussent pour le texte
version Sénat c'est ce qu'on dit
dit-vous Benjamin dad vous nous direz si
c'est vrai il y a des listes qui
circulent 15 20 députés renaissan qui
pourraient s'abstenir ou voir même voter
contre le texte s'il était trop durci
par le Sénat on entend aussi qu'à la fin
tout le monde renterra dans le rang ou
encore certains préféraient tout
simplement que le texte soit abandonné
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
responsable du texte pour la majorité et
bien ils vont consulter appeler chacun
des députés pour connaître leur état
d'esprit leur lign rougge pour essayer
de jauger un petit peu effectivement les
effectifs du groupe alors pour bien
comprendre Elsa il y a plusieurs
scénarios sur la la table il y a celui
d'une commission mixte paritaire
conclusive qui serait donc validée
ensuite par les députés il y a celui bah
d'un échec de la commission mixte
paritaire et d'un abandon du texte et
puis il y a un troisième scénario oui un
scénario qui sera encore un scénario
catastrophe c'est-à-dire une commission
mixte paritaire conclusive mais dont le
vote serait rejeté à l'Assemblée ça peut
être et bien faute de faire le planin
chez les républicains ou alors si trop
de voix manquent dans la majorité il
peut y avoir du suspense jusqu'au bout
donc ce qu'on sait c'est que les
consultations vont se poursuivre tout le
weekend Elisabeth borne elle continue à
négocier elle se démène elle espère
peut-être sauver son avenir politique
même si d'autres sont beaucoup plus
pessimiste pour elle écoutez ce que dit
un député de la majorité en cas d'accord
et en cas de réussite elle sauve les
fesses de Darmanin sauf que son sort
politique elle et scellé c'est terminado
on n a pas fini avec les conséquences de
ce projet de loi immigration merci
beaucoup elsamandingava Benjamin Hadad
vous venez de la droite de l'UMP on l'a
vu dans le portrait de Marco Pomier ça a
été évoqué par par Elsa à l'instant vous
entendez ceux qui eux viennent de la
gauche au sein de la majorité et qui ont
le sentiment aujourd'hui un peu qu'on
est en train de leur tordre le bras mais
vous savez la première ministre avec le
ministre deintérieur s'est engagé dans
cette négociation avec beaucoup de
détermination beaucoup de comativité les
Français attendent de nous qu'on trouve
des résultats et qu'on arrive à obtenir
un accord pr à quel prix pour la
majorité nous avons nous avons nous
avons nos lignes rouges on les a exprimé
on a un négociateur maintenant
effectivement on a eu le résultat avec
le vote de la motion de rejet donc on
doit en prendre en prendre acte euh moi
j'espère qu'on pourra trouver un
compromis pour pouvoir avoir une une
politique de de fermeté de maîtrise de
l'immigration en particulier de lutte
contre l'immigration illégale c'est un
texte qui permet d'expulser jusqu'à 4000
délinquants étrangers je crois que c'est
attendu par les Français vous savez moi
j'ai toujours considéré que en en
politique même quand on est engagé avec
ces convictions on n' pas le monopole de
la vérité et de l'intérêt général on
peut faire des compromis on peut
travailler avec les autres là on a des
sénateurs encore une fois on part pas du
même endroit sur ce texte c'est vrai
mais c'est aussi à ça ça que sert la
Commission parétaire et cette
négociation donc j'espère qu'elle
aboutira et qu'on pourra voter ce texte
vous êtes prêt à aller jusqu'où pour
obtenir un accord quand a dit bah d'un
côté il y a effectivement cette envie
d'aller vers un accord et ce risque de
faire exploser la majorité êtes-v vous
prêt à renoncer à un accord si vous
sentez que ça tank trop fort chez vous
mais on a eu déjà ces discussions on a
en ce moment ces échanges au sein de la
majorité on a des sensibilité évidemment
qu'on respecte sur ce sujet qui est un
sujet qui est très important très
passionnel pour beaucoup d'entre nous
qui avons tous nos nos histoires nos
engagements personnels on a un texte qui
est un texte d'équilibre qui permet de
mieux intégrer aussi par la langue et le
travail qui permet aussi d'avoir une
politique d'autorité et de fermeté sur
l'immigration ce sont ces équilibres
naturellement que l'on veut que l'on
veut respecter et après trouver un
compromis un accord encore une fois pour
défendre l'Inter régional et répondre à
l'exigence aujourd'hui des Français qui
est d'avoir une politique sur
l'immigration et de trouver des résultat
ensemble pour vous il est il est
envisageable ça fait partie des
hypothèses que un accord trouvé en
commission ex paritaire ne soit pas
validé dans l'hémicycle par l'Assemblée
travaillons d'abord à trouver un accord
en
commissionire et après bah vous savez
quand on s'engag en politique il y a
toujours le risque de perdre que ce soit
de perdre des votes à l'Assemblée
nationale ou de perdre des élections
donc on se bat d'abord pour trouver un
accord avec les sénateurs et puis après
pour dégager une majorité Merci à VOUS
Benjamin Adad on passe à Bertrand
Perrier bonsoir vous revenez ce soir sur
la circulaire qui a été prise en 2021
par Jean-Michel Blanquer qui était alors
ministre de l'éducation nationale sur la
façon dont on accueille les élèves
transgenres dans le dans le système
éducatif français c'est une circulaire
qui a fait l'objet de plusieurs recours
d'association l'audience a eu lieu cet
après-midi racontez-nous oui alors
effectivement en en 2021 Jean-Michel
Blanquer avait pris à destination de
l'ensemble de la communauté éducative
une circulaire pour favoriser
l'intégration des élèves transgenre dans
le milieu scolaire l'idée générale était
d'une écoute bienveillante et trois
propositions majeures avaient émergé de
cette circulaire la première eu c'était
que lorsque l'élève choisissait un
nouveau prénom et bien si les parents
étaient d'accord et bien c'est ce
nouveau prénom qui était utilisé sur les
listes d'appel sur les cartes de cantine
sur les cartes de bibliothèque il y
avait une deuxième idée c'est que on ne
pouvait pas faire des restrictions
vestimentaires en fonction du genre
c'est-à-dire que un garçon pouvait
mettre une jupe s'il se considère fille
et puis la troisième chose évidemment
qui était la plus crispante la plus
cristallisante de tension c'était les
vestiaires c'était les dortoirs c'était
les toilettes et donc la circulaire
recommandait que les établissements
permettent à un élève se déclarant d'un
autre genre que celui de son apparence
d'aller dans les toilettes les dortoirs
et les vestiaires de l'autre gens et
donc cette circulaire a provoqué une
levée de bouclier du côté de plusieurs
associations catholiques oui c'est ça il
y a eu plusieurs associations qui se
sont ému de de cette circulaire en
expliquant c'était le cœur de leur
argumentation que en réalité le droit à
ce nouveau prénom le droit à cette
utilisation des toilettes de l'autre
genre était purement déclaratif c'estàd
qu'il suffisait de se dire garçon Sion
est une fille ou fille si on est un
garçon pour obtenir ses droits en tant
que transg il n'y avait pas d'examen
médical il n'y avait pas d'accord des
parents et donc l'élève par sa seule
affirmation et bien en quelque sorte
imposait son genre son pronom son prénom
à des professeurs à des camarades de
classe et à l'ensemble de la communauté
éducative avec en filigrane l'idée que
cette revendication d'une transidentité
à une période où l'ident é se construit
pode de l'adolescence pouvait être un
peu fragile un peu influençable un peu
réversible à une période justement de de
quête d'identité ou de reconnaissance et
il y a donc eu un recours au Conseil
d'État et l'audience avait lieu cet
après-midi qu'est-ce qui s'y est dit
alors le rapporteur public qui est un
magistrat indépendant mais qui est
souvent suivi a conclu au rejet de la
requête des associations la réponse sera
donnée par le conseiltat d'ici la fin de
l'année mais indépendamment des
questions purement juridiques ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que la transidentité
n'est pas une tocade c'est pas un
caprice c'est pas une lub W ou
post-moderne c'est une réalité c'est un
sentiment que l'on vit que l'on vit
souvent d'ailleurs douloureusement et
quand on sait les moqueries les colibé
les stigmatisations dont font l'objet
non seulement en classe mais ailleurs
les élèves qui revendiquent ainsi une
identité de gens différent de celle
qu'ils avaientent à leur naissance et
bien je crois qu'on pourrait pas dire
que le fait simplement de considérer
cette réalité ce fait social serait une
sorte d'encouragement on n'encourage pas
la transidentité la transidentité c'est
un fait et il n'y a pas l'idée que l'on
favoriserait ainsi l'émergence de cette
revendication ce d'autant que s'il y a
parfois effectivement des variations
identitaires et bien il faut au
contraire les accompagner et donc
j'ajoute une dernière chose c'est que la
transidentité n'est pas une maladie elle
ne suppose pas un certificat médical
elle ne suppose pas non plus un
traitement médical elle ne suppose pas
une opération c'est un état c'est
effectivement un ressenti ça existe et
une école qui l'ignorerait ça ferait
mauvais genre Merci à VOUS Bertrand
Perrier Mariette dargrand un mot à
retenu votre attention dans l'actualité
de la semaine un mot employé par Gérald
daranin après le vote de la motion de
rejet sur la loi immigration il s'agit
de politiie exactement ça m'a beaucoup
amusé le l'arrivée de ce mot j'ai pensé
que c'était un ééologisme une création
sémiologique c'est toujours intéressant
parce que il faut reconnaître que les
politiques en font assez peu mais après
vérification en fait non c'est un mot
qui est assez ancien existe vraiment ça
existe ça existe depuis la fin du 19e
probablement créé par le l'écrivain
Jules valè vous savez qui défendait la
commune c'està-dire une façon de faire
de la politique contre la façon
traditionnelle et pour lui la
politiille c'était un peu comme la
flicaille ou la piétaille donc c'était
forcément quelque chose de péjoratif
c'était péjoratif il y a pas de doute et
je crois que Gérald Darmanin s'est
inscrit dans cette manière péjorative il
a voulu dénoncer les deal les
marchandages qui avait eu lieu entre
selon lui entre les députés de tout bord
contre la majorité alors ça n'est pas
faux c'est normal qu'il ait eu cette
analogie d'une certaine façon mais quand
même je voudrais dire que c'est pas très
gentil pour le commerce pourquoi puisque
la la quincayerie qui est dedans en fait
on entend aussi le mot valise hein
politique plus qu'un ci égal politique
ci alors oui c'est des deals oui c'est
du commerce mais le commerce c'est pas
mal et en particulier je dois dire que
ce commerce de la quincaillerie il
m'intéresse personnellement comme
observatrice de la société parce qu'il
se porte très bien figurez-vous hein
dans un moment où nous voulons réparer
nos objets nous voulons bricoler nous
voulons jardiner et ben ces ces
commerces de proximité sont évidemment
c'est le bazar hein un peu comme on a vu
dans dans l'hémicycle mais ça a de
l'intérêt et alors j'ai regardé juste
par curiosité la formation à ces métiers
il y a des nouvelles formations un cap
spécialisé à Bac pro et cetera alors
qu'est-ce qu'on demande aux gens qui
qu'est-ce qu'ils apprennent les jeunes
dans ces formations là ils apprennent le
sens de l'écoute j'invente pas he j'ai
vu sur les sur les sites d'orientation
sens de l'écoute empathie et façon de
pouvoir comprendre les problèm des gens
avec des solutions concrètes mais je
trouve que c'est pas mal pour les donc
c'estd que politique AR c'est pas si
négatif finalement c'est pas si négatif
alors ce qui est négatif c'est la
parlotte hein et d'ailleurs dans le
dictionnaire le Trésor de la langue
française politique àé c'est parler
faire beaucoup de bruit pour rien parler
avec des mots creux de politique donc ça
on va laisser de côté et ça veut dire
que certains concepts un peu de de
péraison du type immigration zéro ou
bien préférence nationale qui ont pas
tellement de chance d'aller dans le réel
hein qui sont des mots des mots assez
creux qui plaisent à certains bah voilà
ça c'est un on pourrait dire que c'est
Politi ça mais en revanche il une
dimension positive sur laquelle je
voudrais insister pour finir Clément
parce que je pense que notre ministre de
l'Intérieur n'a pas fait exprès c'était
bon il voulait être négatif mais
n'empêche que il a soulevé un livère
intéressant à mon avis c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on appelle la politique
domestique c'est la politique
précisément de l'intérieur c'est la
d'omous la maison euh la maison France
et al nous savons tous que la maison
France et bien elle a besoin d'être
réparée sous beaucoup de d'aspects
aujourd'hui Merci à VOUS Mariette
darigrand merci à nos trois affranchis
de ce soirée à vous Benjamin Hadad
d'avoir été notre grand témoin ça vous
regarde c'est donc terminé pour cette
semaine vous retrouverez Miriam Ankawa
des mardi prochain d'ici là passez une
bonne soirée et un bon weekend sur
[Musique]
LCP